men should be able to cheat freely
without getting caught yeah oh make it
illegal dude yeah that's so [__] up to
their cheating privacy yeah that's what
I'm saying yeah a guy can't cheat in
peace
you guys know those
um street photography slo-mo videos in
China of like people walking
and then they're like doing uh fashion
right yeah they do fashion or it'll be
like a hot woman or something like that
whatever you know it's because they do
that just for that on that street yep oh
really it's like their own like like
Melrose or like fashion like no it's
like their Third Street Promenade
because it's like like go to be seen
pillow retails there and you'll see like
the background where people are all
dressed up ready to go and they're
waiting their turn and then like there's
there's on this side hello photographers
and whatever and then they do their turn
like it was like a little Runway that's
cool and then they they walk yeah they
walk off yeah here's an example of one
that
caused an interesting stir
[Music]
streak but yeah kind of Fire
do they normally not walk with a male no
I think
it's the the overall look right what's
the look I mean
like a nerdy dude yeah it's like it
looks like a a sugar baby situation yes
yes
sorry not dirty but
sugar babies can you play that one more
time
yeah I think all the guys were just
looking at the lady that's why we didn't
pay attention except for subin
looks like Nelson from [__] Simpsons
Nelson you know Nelson which I'm a Mill
House Milhouse yeah
we do we knew the conversion so Nelson's
the bully he's wearing
so this got a lot of heat because
that guy is a Chinese exec and he's
cheating and he's cheating on his wife
oh I was supposed to know that is that
that's his mistress
and is that is it like alipapa.com or
something no it's it's Chinese petroleum
Engineers or something that's the
Chinese
they counted in Alibaba like a sugar
babies no so I said money yeah why is he
so bad at Mr sizing yeah what is he I
don't know why he took her to a public
Street like there's a lot of guys that
just openly date their mistress like
dude oh really when you're in tourist
towns like it might be a power play too
oh uh me and Hannah we play this game uh
hooker or influencer and uh that's a
good game it's a really awesome game too
and well some of the weirdest couples
situations that I've seen are like they
look like father daughter situations but
she's a little too revealing
and a little too
flirty and then they just sometimes make
out so you clearly they're not father
daughter situations but then like
I was walking down this
down just so cute father that's not a
daughter
that's like a hot mistress bring your
being your girlfriend your other three
girlfriends situations yeah same with
Vegas Vegas yeah it's a fun place to
just stand and people watch and you'll
see it all the time yeah
so he was caught cheating his wife the
company fired him wow I mean that
happens dude yeah what because that
video got 17 million views holy [__] and
what do you think
happens now they got a bunch of brand
deals that's interesting she left them
to to fire somebody based off of like
moral principles versus that's Asian
style it's Asian style it's Shame Shame
on your family shame yeah well Asia but
I think that's that [__] happens out
here too though like yeah it gets like
political you know because it's like
okay you're you're selling our business
brand name like like to Bill Clinton
right now that was chill yeah I feel
like they would have done that in the
50s here like there's some huge Scandal
because of some cheating but like now
it's probably more like so yeah some
proprietary knowledge the apology just
publicly fired him but he's still
probably working for the company
you know what's funny too is is China I
guess like at least from my experience
when I was like working with like a big
company
dumb dudes was getting hookers bro like
they're all married but then the thing
is I can understand that if one of them
got caught yeah they would have to sever
ties and be like you don't know how to
play this game right yeah because it's
more of a thing of like what are you
stupid exactly it's more of that it's
like they can't trust you now yeah
because you could blow it up for
everybody yeah dude loopholes I mean not
loopholes they're like sorry man now you
got to be a consultant none of that's a
stupid type that every company does that
but like I could understand I mean there
is the dark dark side of business right
so high level businesses the way that
they operate is like well how can you
trust this person so then they play
these stupid games like let's all get
drunk as [__] so then like you might see
how they handle their liquor and if they
spill under pressure is this some like
my my buddy does business out there a
lot and he was telling me like the type
of weird [__] that goes down like
they'll all just go to a brothel
together and then it's like they all
cheat on their wives together as a I
have collateral yeah now you can really
because you can't just be like hey trust
me bro it's like we're we're dealing
with hundreds of millions of dollars
like how can I really trust you he goes
well we'll both commit something bad
together and then we'll have dirt on
each other and then we can do business
because you know that you can screw me
over the way I can screw you over is
there another way no nope no blood oats
it's like what about a contract because
like that [__] doesn't work and then and
then you go I still don't trust you I
think we have to go do it again yeah and
again and again at least once a week I
think we have to do each other
[Laughter]
odd um there's a funny resulting thing
that happened because of this clip and
it's not to do with him being fired
women everywhere are dying to get that
dress oh [__] so now the dress is being
sold no dresses they don't give a [__]
you're just like she looks so hot that's
a tight dress they're all looking at it
like we want the mistress dress where do
we get the mistress dress marketing is
crazy marketing is crazy dude yeah the
whole time there really is no bad press
on no bro I mean she does she looks
great in it
yeah I was thinking about wearing that
dress too when I saw her walking out
that's the bag of billionaire dress yeah
yeah if I wear this like a bag of Billy
Billy so that's that's kind of what's
Happening Now is women are trying to
find where to get it I wanna dude if I
was a mistress I I want to be a Chinese
guys mistress you want to be a Chinese
guy's mistress yeah he looks like he
would be nice to me yeah yeah like the
way that he looks like even if he's into
kinky [__] it probably wouldn't hurt
that much it looks like doesn't brush
his teeth
he might be a little gross looking but
like dude I mean this versus like a
hairy ass big old dude that's like six
foot something true like why you gotta
talk about azerbaijani people like that
man yeah that's true I'm just kidding
it's all right look look middle house or
asthma yeah
asthma that's that from poor bat Borat
dude Oh I thought you were making oh no
his [__] camera guy yeah he's funny
that guy's great so you know the funny
meme about like uh girls don't tag their
sponsors right when they go on there on
the boat and then you'll see a group of
these guys on the yacht they're like
[__] 300 pounds super they look like
they just stink like cigar and cologne
attackers yes the tag your sponsors so
right and it's like these are the guys
they're going on the Yachts with the
other side the other side right I'm like
oh girl like you deserve whatever you're
making because that's work yeah that's a
lot to deal with yeah but this guy like
this guy he he could be my girlfriend
you know what I mean like he looks like
he'll be nice like he looks like he
likes deep conversations and he'll come
in two minutes oh my god get yourself a
jackpot right
he'll come to deep conversations exactly
so what do you think back it up what do
you think about this now it's coming
into debate whether or not street
photography should be allowed oh my God
because of situations like this this is
so [__] foolish do you think street
photography is a do you think that's a
breach of Soulful part of you
around
I think so do you think it is
men should be able to cheat freely
without getting caught yeah oh make it
illegal dude yeah that's so [__] up to
their cheating privacy yeah that's what
I'm saying yeah a guy can't cheat in
peace
what if I identify as a cheater huh
that's who I am because these guys that
are like they want these Mistresses
right they they want the romance even if
it's bought that's why he's on a date
like looking good like or else he would
just have a hooker sent to his room but
he's on a date because he wants you
don't think you don't think he picked
that shirt out what they should do is
show a picture of his wife and then
you're like oh okay that's fine that's
fine I understand
because you know like these billionaires
yeah the ones that cheat yeah when you
see their day ones you're like oh that's
a charm
here's his wife
you liar liar
but show her now though show her now
it's always something at least
I feel like doesn't that come with a
territory though like if I was a lady
and I was like marrying a billionaire
like after the fact that he's a
billionaire not that we got together
like in high school and then like he
built himself up that way but like if
I'm going for that then I would assume
that he's [__] whoever he wants yeah
like I don't really think there's at
that level guys can be loyal I don't
know because they have everything at
their disposal well also because now
that I know a lot of things about the
business and the things that they do
it's almost like they don't they might
not even want to [__] the girl but like
it's this like
like that oh you want to work with Sony
all right well we're gonna have an orgy
and we're gonna have a Coke party so
you're gonna join us yeah and he's like
[__] okay yeah I guess I have to Mr
Toyota you know like that's Hollywood
too you know right yeah and then at that
level it's just it's just like maybe
it's not even personal desire and fun
but it's like just a step yeah yeah I
don't know now it sounds like we're
fresh and fit podcast
that's what they always say they're like
men at the top level like the top
percent that women all want I would I
would assume that is the norm but I
would think like I would want the the
the the the opposite which is like a
loyal good loving sure yeah predictable
good I think there's still people who
abide by their own morals and principles
regardless of their money you like those
kind of guys yeah the people that abide
by their own morals and principles yeah
absolutely nerds yeah nerds idiots
morons I I think I think rips I think I
think if they're Mormon
I would be religious I would be
religious have you ever dated a Mormon
no no they're really clean they're clean
will you please yeah so will you please
can you just try it give it a go
if it's good content yeah oh see she
knows good content see maybe I was
thinking about Asians
too much I should think about Mormons
yeah Mormons a Mormon billionaires
Mormon billionaires Untouchable dude
yeah they won't cheat they'll just get
multiple times so if somebody gave you a
billion dollars tomorrow
I'd be cheating all day no
I think the I it's not it's not
like I I became one so it's like if you
already are aiming for one then you have
to expect
a different because you go through the
levels of evolution to get there let me
uphold like your your values through
through that process but I think those
are unicorns
who become billionaires who completely
toss out their principles because they
now have a completely different
lifestyle yeah it happens a lot like Mr
Amazon
but not Warren Buffett he still eats the
same McDonald's every morning with the
same wife so before before we end what
do you think about that
as someone who cheats what do you think
keep the [__] frame it that way it's
not good
[Music]
foreign